today the Matt Walsh show a university
in Michigan holds segregated graduation
ceremonies this has become a popular
Trend in Academia meanwhile Robin
D'Angelo openly advocates for
segregation using the same language that
Scott Adams used yet D'Angelo has
suffered no repercussions while Adams
had his life destroyed we'll talk about
all this today plus the Santa speaks out
against the possible politically
motivated arrest of Donald Trump but
Trump and his supporters aren't happy
with the way that DeSantis spoke out
also we finally have more information
revealing why those cops and Uvalde sat
outside the classroom while children
were being executed and the New
Revelations are somehow even more
damning and the cast of Ted lasso visit
the white visits the White House why
exactly were they at the White House
well we're still trying to figure that
out all of that and more today on Matt
Walsh
[Music]
foreign
has consequences as the feds raise
interest rates to combat out-of-control
government spending long-term bonds have
diminished in value crippling banks
depositors are holding their breath and
investors are bailing on Bank stocks
diversification has never been more
important the recent surge in gold
prices is directly tied to the extreme
Market volatility right now that's why
gold has historically been a great hedge
against stock market and inflation you
can trust Birch gold group to help you
diversify in to Gold Tex Walsh to 989898
to get a free info kit on gold Birch
gold will help you convert an existing
Ira or 401K that's tied to a volatile
Market into an IRA and physical precious
metals like gold and silver the best
part is it's tax shelters so just text
Walsh to 98 98 98 to get your free info
kit on gold to claim eligibility for
your free save then talk to one of their
precious metals Specialists that's Walsh
to 98 98 98 today
last night somebody sent me an email
that had recently gone out to students
at Grand Valley State University in
Michigan the email was meant to inform
them about the five upcoming graduation
celebrations which would be held as a
compliment to the commencement ceremony
now five celebrations might seem a
little bit excessive if you've ever been
if you've ever been to a graduation then
you know that one is already a little
bit too much as it is but there's a
reason why this school has decided to
have five as they explained in their
email reading out says Dear Laker
graduates Grand Valley hosts five unique
graduation celebrations annually
designed to honor our diverse graduates
these programs complement the University
commencement ceremonies and are an
opportunity to come together and
acknowledge Laker accomplishments in the
spirit and traditions of our diverse
identities and cultures
and here are the five events
it says Asian graduation celebration
April 19th black graduation celebration
April 28th Latinos slash a slash ex
graduation celebration April 28th
side note
um no Hispanic person actually wants to
be called latinx but rather than simply
abandon that silliness entirely this is
apparently what they've settled on now
Latino people are Latino slash a slash X
so they've improved on latinx which
sounded clunky and ridiculous by coming
up with an alternative that is even
clunkier and more ridiculous
um okay back to the segregated
graduations
uh it says lavender graduation
celebrating lgbtqia plus graduates April
20th native graduation celebration April
27th
side note again there is a typo here
actually because it actually says
lavender gradation gradation as in a
series of successive changes made by
degrees or in phases over time much like
you would find on say a slippery slope
so this typo is the most insightful
thing this university has produced in
its entire existence probably even if it
was by accident
so these are the graduation celebrations
or gradation celebrations however you
want to put it broken up by identity
group now needless to say there will be
no special event for straight white
people they they will have to make do
with the commencement ceremony that
everybody else gets they're not going to
get their own special event
but Grand Valley is far from alone with
their segregation policies when it comes
to graduations this has become an
increasingly common practice just a
couple of weeks ago there was
controversy over a segregated black
graduation ceremony at the University of
Chicago The Daily Mail had that reported
said quote a leaked email obtained by
University of Chicago Law student
Benjamin Ogilvy unmasked the previously
under wrapped event with Ogilvie Penning
at peace for the college fix to share
the email's contents quote black action
and public policy studies is hosting a
graduation ceremony for all University
of Chicago black graduate students on
June 1st the email stated according to
Ogilvy leaked on Tuesday the email
reportedly touted the event as the
culmination of the black student
experience at the Illinois school and
has already sparking heated discourse as
to whether or not the event serves as
segregation
now a spokesperson for the school was
quoted later in the article and they
they did respond to a request for
comment arguing that the black
graduation though it is a ceremony being
held for black people and is advertised
as such is not explicitly black only and
so that's how they get around any you
know legal uh challenges
anyone can come if they want to
technically
and the fact that whites won't be chased
away at gunpoint not as an official
policy anyway is supposed to make this
all okay and yet I have a sneaking
suspicion that the University of Chicago
would not allow a white graduation
ceremony even if blacks were technically
allowed to attend
the logic as always only goes one way
the same applies at Harvard where
Harvard's office of equity diversity
inclusion and belonging helps to
organize graduation ceremonies for quote
first generation
bgltq black and latinct students they've
also added a special Ceremony this year
for Asian American Pacific Islander and
Desi American graduates
Columbia University meanwhile adds
another category
that school has special Ceremonies for
black lgbtq native latinx and Asian
graduates just like we saw with Grand
Valley they've also added a sixth
category for low-income individuals
because it is of course important to
have proper representation for all of
those impoverished people who are
graduating from an Ivy League school
the low income celebration will be very
interesting because there won't be
anyone there except the catering staff I
guess
so this
is the country we live in now
segregation has long since made a
comeback these policies can be put in
place they can be advocated for and most
of the time uh without even the
slightest pushback
that is as long as you advocate for them
from a socially acceptable angle
so take this recent clip of white
fragility author Robin D'Angelo claiming
that black people need to quote get away
from white people listen
and then I'm a big believer in Affinity
space and Affinity work and I think
people of color need to get away from
white people and and have some Community
um with each other and I'll I'll let
that go and maybe see if anyone else
wants to pick it up
yes get away she says get away
one racial group needs to get away from
the other
now if this sentiment sounds familiar
probably because Scott Adams the creator
of Dilbert said exactly the same thing
almost verbatim with one slight
difference let's listen to that again I
would say you know based on the current
way things are going the best advice I
would give to white people is to get the
hell away from black people
just get the away
wherever you have to go just get away
because there's no fixing this
this can't be fixed
right this can't be fixed you just have
to escape
so it is as I said exactly the same idea
using almost identical language
the difference is that Scott Adams lost
everything his career his reputation
distribution of his comic strip he had
his life destroyed for saying what you
just heard there
meanwhile Robin D'Angelo has suffered no
repercussions at all
it's not that D'Angelo has experienced a
less intense backlash or less severe
professional consequences is that there
has been no backlash no consequence
and that's all because though they both
were advocating for the same thing
D'Angelo said that blacks need to get
away from whites well Adam said that
whites need to get away from blacks
this is the crucial distinction that's
supposed to change everything
according to the new rules
you can divide the races you can
segregate and separate you can certainly
call for one group to get away from
another and you can phrase it just like
that you can pretty much say whatever
you want about race relations and
advocate for any sort of solution that
you want provided that you keep white
people situated in their assigned place
as the bad guys the antagonists
here's the crucial mistake that Scott
Adams made he implied
that there may be some troubling Trends
within the black community that would
give white people reason to be wary
but this interferes with the hero versus
villain storyline that the left has
invented it can only ever be blacks
escaping the hatred and violence of
whites never the other way around the
idea that there may be hatred and
violence against whites that they might
want to escape is anathema
which is not to say that it's inaccurate
but here's the important point that is
what I think people need to understand
this is not just a racial double
standard intended to villainize white
people I mean it is that
but at a deeper level the point
is that white people are not allowed to
advocate for themselves as a group
that's what this is okay
that's what people miss about the
reaction to Scott Adams it's assumed
that he was canceled because he said
something that paints black people in a
negative light but that's not really it
because the reaction would have been
just as Intense or nearly as intense if
he had said that white people need to
say uh you know have pride and
self-esteem or white people need to make
sure they get educated white people need
to work hard and succeed
doesn't matter
if he had said anything to advocate for
the well-being of white people as a
group even if he had if it had nothing
to do with segregation nothing to do
with anything like that he would still
be condemned
and if you don't believe me then just go
out in public sometime and say that
white people should have larger families
and reproduce more
now you aren't calling for segregation
you aren't saying anything negative
about any other race yet it is
guaranteed to be treated just as harshly
as the comments Scott Adams made because
this is what the race Hustlers on the
left are trying to guard against they
want other racial groups to have a sense
of community a sense of identity and
belonging within the group
they want those groups to advocate for
themselves they want those groups to be
concerned with the flourishing of their
groups but they stridently oppose any
similar move
for whites to do that as well because
they do not want whites to see
themselves as a group
at bottom they don't want whites to have
a racial identity and they will tell you
this directly if you ask them if you ask
for example why
um black pride and brown pride are okay
more than okay they're actively good
but white pride is horrendously racist
they will inform you that whites have no
real racial identity the category is too
broad and vague thus they argue white
pride must really be an expression of
hatred towards non-whites
I mean you can't have white right it
doesn't make any sense they say because
it's a group that doesn't really it
doesn't mean anything
they will simply expect you not to
notice that black and brown are
categories just as broad just as vague
as white
doesn't matter
black and brown can and should have a
sense of racial identity white must not
I mean that's the rule and it's why
segregation can be promoted and instated
as policy but only to give non-whites
their special spaces never to do this to
do the same for whites because to do the
same would be to acknowledge the
existence of white people as a group and
to give that group permission to care
about its own well-being
now this principle doesn't just apply to
race of course and they do the same
thing with sex the same thing with
sexual orientation
LGBT people can have their own spaces
they can advocate for themselves as a
group heterosexuals cannot women can
have their own spaces
well they used to anyway and they can
advocate for themselves as a group men
cannot
ultimately you know the straight white
male is left as the one category of
person on Earth who has who has no
category no identity group that he's
allowed to belong to or advocate for
he must subsume he must be subsumed into
one of these other groups by identifying
as a woman or as gay or else he'll be
left with no group
and that's the real goal
of course the goal can never be finally
achieved
that goal can't anyway
and in pursuing that goal all of the
nightmare scenarios you're allegedly
trying to guard against are only now
guaranteed to happen
because pendulum pendulums always swing
back
and by singling out one group as the
antagonist and insisting that all other
groups are allowed to do and say things
that this group is not
you are ensuring that when that group
does start to coalesce it will do so
largely around a shared feeling of
resentment and exclusion
and a not a not baseless feeling of
and nothing good comes from that
unless of course your goal is the
destabilization of society as we know it
in which case this is a very efficient
way to achieve it
now let's get to our five headlines
if you've been paying attention to the
news you know that the FDA has declared
a global shortage of medication they're
warning that critical antibiotics are
still an extremely short supply we all
had a good laugh when there were toilet
paper shortages at the start of the
pandemic I mean some people laughed
about it I guess uh then when there was
a baby formula shortage things were not
so funny anymore what about when there
is a shortage of emergency medications
you need to be prepared for anything and
our partners at Jace medical are here to
help with that a great way to start
preparing is with the Jace case which is
a pack of five different courses of
antibiotics that you can use to treat a
whole host of bacterial illnesses
including UTIs respiratory infections
skin infections and much more all you
have to do is fill out a simple online
form your information will be reviewed
by a board certified physician and your
medication will be dispensed by a
licensed pharmacy at a fraction of the
regular cost the Jay's case gives me
peace of mind knowing that my family
will have what we need if the worst
happens
and you can also find the same Peace of
Mind by going to jacemedical.com enter
promo code wall should check out for a
discount on your order that's
jacemedical.com promo code Walsh
okay report from the daily wire
Republican uh Florida Republican
Governor Ron DeSantis responded on
Monday to reports that former president
Donald Trump could be indicted this week
calling the situation A manufactured
Circus by a prosecutor trying to Virtue
signal for his base the Santa's remarks
come after Trump claimed over the
weekend that he was going to be arrested
on Tuesday in connection with the
prosecution by Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg's office involving
an alleged hush money payment to porn
actress Stormy Daniels in 2016 a
spokesperson for Trump later said that
Trump has been given no notification
that there will be an arrest next week
um
and in fact we can say now that uh that
there almost certainly will not be an
arrest today so this was the claim that
was made there's gonna be arrest on
Tuesday and it seems certain that that's
not going to happen whether there will
be an arrest in the future uh
if at all Still Remains to be seen
um
but Rhonda Sanders did comment on this
as he was asked in a press conference
and let's just watch the uh the whole
clip of what he said
so I've seen rumor swirl I have not seen
any facts uh yet and so I don't know
what's going to happen but I do know
this the the Manhattan district attorney
is a Soros funded prosecutor and so he
like other Soros funded prosecutors they
weaponized their office to impose a
political agenda on Society at the
expense of the rule of law and Public
Safety he has downgraded over 50 percent
of the felonies to misdemeanors he says
he doesn't want to even have jail time
for the vast vast majority of crimes and
what we've seen in Manhattan is we've
seen the sky the crime rate go up and
we've seen citizens become less safe and
so you're talking about this situation
with and look I don't know what goes
into paying hush money to a porn star to
to secure silence over some type of
alleged Affair I just I can't speak to
that
I also said that uh we're not involved
in this we won't be involved in this I
have no interest in getting involved in
some type of type of manufactured Circus
by Soros some Soros D.A he's trying to
do a political spectacle he's trying to
Virtual signal first phase
um
so
uh so that was his answer
now Trump did not like that answer
um and especially among Trump supporters
just just looking at least on Twitter
anyway uh it was it was roundly panned
by not just Trump supporters but Trump
supporters in particular were very upset
with what uh Ron said especially that
bit at the end there of the little dig
about not knowing you know he doesn't
know what goes into paying hush money to
a porn star which by the way I I don't
either I mean that's a it's a valid
thing to point out it's like we don't
know all the particulars and what goes
into that
um Trump didn't like the answer he
thought it wasn't uh sufficiently
passionate I I guess and he responded
reading from daily wire now former
president Donald Trump took aim at
Florida Republican Governor Ron DeSantis
on Monday after the governor addressed
reports the progressive Manhattan
district attorney Alvin Bragg is heading
to charge the former president
um we just heard his comments Trump said
Rhonda sanctimonious will probably find
out about false accusations and fake
stories sometime in the future as he
gets older wiser and better known when
he's unfairly and illegally attacked by
a woman even classmates that are
underage or possibly a man I'm sure
he'll want to fight these Misfits just
like I do
and then Trump provided in that tweet
wasn't a tweet actually it was on his
truth social page uh what do they call
it a truth I think they refer to it as a
truth I'm sending a truth
um which this is not neither here nor
there but I cannot think of a worse word
to turn into a verb
um you know in social media I'm truthing
as if everything you happen to say on
social media is automatically true but
anyway
um
he he accompanied that post with a
picture that he has posted before of Ron
DeSantis when apparently he was a
teacher standing with some uh at a some
kind of party with former students and
there's nothing inappropriate happening
in the picture they're literally just
standing there taking a picture uh but
Trump in the past has insinuated that
that somehow DeSantis was involved in
grooming and then he was
he was amplifying that charge yet again
in that response so
I'll say a few things about this
um
from what I've seen again on social
media which In fairness is social media
not exactly known for a place where you
get a lot of uh well-regulated emotions
and all the rest of it so uh I've seen
the people who are passionate supporters
around Santa say that this was a this
was a brilliant response it was the best
response I could possibly offer and then
we've got passion and supporters of
Donald Trump saying it's an app it's an
absolute disaster it's the worst that
you have ever could have said it's it it
destroys everything is you can't support
them anymore because of it so I've seen
both of these extreme reactions and uh
this is one case where I'm gonna go
somewhere in the middle now I will say
that my first reaction to Ron Sands is a
statement
was I didn't love it I didn't love the
statement and I still don't
um and even though as you know I'm a
supporter of Ron DeSantis I'm not going
to
uh I'm a supporter I'm not a fan I will
never be a fan of a politician and the
difference between a supporter and a fan
when you're a supporter it's uh you have
your eyes open and you support them
because of the things they do or say if
they do or say something you don't like
then you're going to speak up a fan is
just blind and Falls along with a call
to personality I don't do that and so I
will say I didn't like
the statement I I it because it didn't
I I think he needed to communicate
um
needed to be from a more firm statement
and he needed to take a stronger stance
now
in my opinion what he said there
was true everything he said is true and
the bit about this being a a Soros
prosecutor and this is a political stunt
and all the rest of it all that is 100
true and that's a good thing for him to
point out
but I think what a lot of people were
looking for is just a stronger stance
um well you didn't get that and say well
I'm not going to get involved and then
throw in the little dig in about the uh
about I don't know what goes into to you
know uh paying off a porn star again
true to true statement but it was a
little dig that he threw at Trump
um which is interesting too because up
to this point Ron DeSantis has
essentially not directly responded to
any of Trump's many many attacks he has
stayed entirely Above The Fray this is
the one time and it wasn't it wasn't
Direct
it wasn't vicious but it was the one
time we saw him kind of needling Trump a
little bit and I think it was the wrong
time for that
you know and usually DeSantis has good
political instincts this was an example
of not having good political instincts
um I think you just have to take a
strong stand and now listen
I can understand
why DeSantis
would not feel particularly motivated
to speak up in very firm and strong
words in defense of trump I can
understand why it would be after all
Trump has been ruthlessly attacking him
unprovoked for months including implying
that he's a groomer and all it's
throwing everything they can at this guy
uh amplifying baseless rumors all the
rest of it now you've got a trump super
Pac that's uh going to the Florida
Election Commission alleged like a
tattletailing to the government on
DeSantis saying that he's uh that he's
running a shadow presidential campaign
and yes that's a trump super Pac it's
not Trump himself but Trump also has not
he certainly hasn't spoken up against it
and said I don't agree with this
and so while Trump's people are going to
the government to try to get DeSantis in
trouble they are insisting that the
Santa speak up in defense of trump
so I can understand if you're from the
Santa's perspective you see all that and
you say I just
screw this guy
but from a personal perspective I can
understand that I can understand that
feeling
but this is one of those occasions where
you have to put your personal feelings
aside as difficult as it might be I'm
not saying I would be I'm not always an
expert when it comes to that sort of
thing putting my personal feelings aside
but this is one of those times when you
have to do that because there's there's
more at stake here you know this is a it
even if they don't go through with the
arrest
the fact that they're even thinking
about this the fact that they're going
down this road at all the fact that they
have spent all this time and money
on investigations and grand juries and
everything
to to potentially try to put a political
rival in jail and the fact that we know
they're only doing it because it's
Donald Trump if Donald Trump's name was
uh you know
Steve Williams or something if his name
was just if he had some any other name a
random name you never heard of
uh Alvin Bragg and
you know the the the the Attorney
General's office uh or rather the the
D.A
in New York
they're not doing any of this we know
that
and I don't think anyone would deny that
so they're specifically doing it because
it's Trump
and because he is they perceive their
number one political enemy
uh if they are able to go through with
this and they're able to do it
especially without serious
um backlash and opposition then we have
entered a new
you know a new era in American politics
and it's not a good one
it's like very troubling to say the
absolute least
and so this is one of those times where
you put all the personal feelings aside
you stand up forcefully
because it's the right thing to do and
also it's politically smart right it's a
it's a it's on top of being the right
thing to do to speak up very forcefully
against this and put all the personal
Jabs and everything aside for this not
only is it the right thing to do for the
country but it's also one of those times
when the right thing to do also happens
to be the politically smart thing to do
and that's not always the case this is
one of those times when it is
um it's politically smart you know
um for Trump for it's really it's like a
power move actually for DeSantis to
speak up in defense of trump
even after Trump has been going after
him to continue to ignore those attacks
and say I'm just doing the right thing
as you know in my position that I have
um I think it's also kind of a
a power move
where Trump now has to has to turn to
DeSantis for help or at least for uh for
advocacy on his behalf I don't think
it's it's not the end of the world for
sandus by any means uh as some people
are painting and I think that's
ridiculous but um I do think that going
forward
the right thing also the smart thing
politically both those things together
is to um is to
forcefully oppose this uh in in whatever
manner you you can legally
um and to not allow any
personal
squabbles to make it into this
would would Trump return the favor if
the situation was reversed
the situation was exactly reversed would
uh would Trump speak up for DeSantis to
try to help him in any way
I tend very much to doubt it but again
that's something you have to put aside
and that's also leadership being able to
being able to put your personal feelings
aside is uh
is a you know
an important element of good leadership
all right
let's see this is from Texas Tribune
a very important update
um
it's going to read some of this here
once they saw a torn of bullets tear
through a classroom wall and metal door
the first police officers in the hallway
of Rob Elementary School concluded they
were out gunned and that they could die
the gunman had an AR-15 a rifle design
used by U.S soldiers in every conflict
since Vietnam its bullets flew towards
the officer at officers at three times
the speed of sound and could have
pierced their body armor like a hole
punch through paper they grazed to
officers in the head and the group were
treated
Uvalde Police Department Sergeant Daniel
Coronado stepped outside breathing
heavily and got on his radio to warn the
others I have a male subject with an AR
Coronado said the dispatch crackled on
the radio of another officer on the
opposite side of the building
f word that officer said AR another
exclaimed alerting others nearby almost
a year after Texas's deadliest school
shooting killed 19 children and two
teachers there's still confusion among
investigators law enforcement leaders
and politicians over how nearly 400 Law
Enforcement Officers could have
performed so poorly people have blamed
cowardice or poor leadership or lack of
sufficient training for why police
waited more than an hour to breach the
classroom and subdue an amateur 18 year
old adversary
but in their own words during during and
after their Bots response the officers
pointed to another reason
they were unwilling to confront the
rifle on the other side of the door
Uvalde Police Department Sergeant Donald
page says you know that it was
definitely an AR there was no way of
going in we had no choice but to wait
and try to get something that had better
coverage where we could actually stand
up to it at Texas Tribune investigation
based on police body cameras emergency
communications and interviews with
investigators that have not been made
public found officers had concluded that
immediately uh confronting the gunman
would be too dangerous even though some
officers were armed with the same rifle
they opted to wait for the arrival of a
border patrol SWAT team with more
protective body armor stronger Shields
and more tactical training even though
the unit was based more than 60 miles
away and it continues that hesitation to
confront the gun the gun allowed the
gunman to terrorize students and
teachers in two classrooms for more than
an hour without interference from police
it delayed medical care for more than
two dozen gunshot victims including
three who were still alive when the
border patrol team finally ended the
shooting but who later died
so this is this is the update we're
finally getting a year later as there
was it says as it says in the article
you know there was always this question
of um
how is it that you had all of these
police officers who were on the scene
and yet this shooting was allowed to
continue for an hour and an hour uh for
a mass shooting is I mean it it may as
well be a decade it's like it's an
unfathomably
um
you know long time for this to be
allowed to continue especially when
there are signings was happening out in
the wilderness somewhere it took this
long to get there they were right there
within moments and yet they allowed this
to continue
and why is that and what we were
originally told if you recall is that
they couldn't get through the door in
fact there was a story originally about
how there was uh it's like reinforced
steel door or something and they
couldn't figure out how to get through
and they were waiting for a key and all
this kind of stuff
and and and to me and so many other
people when we originally heard that
even without having all the facts that
just didn't ring true it's like are you
telling me that but they
've got all these police officers there
and you don't know how to get through a
door you don't have the ability to get
through a door somehow
are there actually doors in this school
that even the police can't get through
that seems like really bad planning
well all that stuff about the door
apparently was total nonsense
because the Uvalde Police Department
immediately after this all happened and
people started asking questions about
how it was allowed to happen for an hour
they started lying to the public
and they came up with one excuse after
another
and it's not until right now that we're
told that oh well they were afraid of
the type of gun that was being used
and it could Pierce their body armor and
they were afraid for their own safety
that's what this was now the left is um
seizing on this to blame the gun
you know the AR and basically let the
cops off the hook
you're never going to hear these people
trying to let the cops off the hook in
any other circumstance
including in many circumstances where
they're trying to put the cops on the
hook
uh sometimes perhaps literally and when
when the cop didn't do anything wrong
in this case you have an absolute
uh inexcusable failure by police
and a a just
unimaginable amount of of cowardice
and what the left wants to say as well
you say it was the titles they are we
got to get the ARs off the street
but this no this this information only
indicts the cops further
because they lied about not being able
to get through the door
that was BS
and what we know now is that they were
simply scared
they were scared for their own safety
and so they made the business decision
that they were going to allow children
to die
um so that so that you know they were
not put In Harm's Way themselves
now these cops were worried about well
our body armor may not withstand what
about the kids in the room
you despicable disgusting cowards did
they have body armor that would
withstand the bullets
no no the kids in the room they didn't
have body armor they also didn't have
ARS themselves to shoot back like you
did
they were not trained Law Enforcement
Officers they were just sitting there as
victims waiting to be executed which so
many of them were
but you're more worried about yourself
and your own safety
and this is uh there's no excuse for it
this is
shameful disgraceful cowardice every
single one of these cops should be
sitting in prison but none of them will
because as it turns out you know the way
the laws are written they don't have any
actual legal obligation to do anything
and that needs to change also
is it easy for me to say sitting here in
the the safety of this studio you know
when I don't have to run in to gunfire I
don't have to run in and face uh and
face a you know a crazed psychopath
shooting an AR in my direction yeah it's
easy for me to say
doesn't make it wrong though doesn't
make what I'm saying wrong
I also didn't sign up for that job see
that's the thing you sign up for the job
if you're not willing I get it it's it's
a it could be a very scary job I can
only imagine running into a school
shooting situation a mass shooting
situation anywhere it's got to be very
scary
but you realize that these things happen
you're becoming a law enforcement
officer if you're not willing to do it
if you're not willing to put yourself In
Harm's Way
and to put your in if you're not willing
to risk your own life
then don't take the job
and the fact that they weren't willing
to do it makes you ask questions about
like well what are you in the job for
what are you you can't claim that you're
doing the job because you just have this
uh unabiding uh desire to help people
and you're some kind of hero that's
clearly not the case
so what the hell are you doing the job
for
this is not one of those well you're
putting your life on your line on the
line to serve the community you clearly
are not interested in doing that
so why do you have the job
now in their case we have to uh suspect
that they have the job what because it's
a they want the benefits and maybe
because they for them it is it is power
you know they're more interested in
having power over people than they are
in serving people I don't think that's
the case by any means for all police
officers
um
I mean to make any blanket statement
about why an entire group of people take
on a certain job would be absurd
and I do think that there are police
officers certainly plenty of them who
take on the job because they want to
serve their communities and and uh and
they want to you know they want to help
people
but for these cops
when the rubber hit the road
they were not there to protect and sir
they're more worried about themselves
this just uh you know when you're as a
police officer it just it doesn't work
if we're saying to police officers
that their own physical safety
can be their top priority
and what we find in that in Uvalde is
that for them as they were in that
school
their own physical safety was top
priority but that doesn't work it can't
be
if your own physical safety is your top
priority don't take that job let someone
else do it
there are there are plenty of jobs and
plenty of things you can do in life
where you can prioritize your own safety
above anything and uh you know it won't
it won't cause a problem
with a cop it just can't be that way
all right so for the daily wire the
White House Press briefing room erupted
on Monday after a reporter from an
Africa focused Outlet accused press
secretary Karine I'm sorry Karen Jean
pair I can't believe I almost said it
correctly of making a mockery of the
First Amendment Gene payer stepped to
the briefing room Podium followed by the
cast of the Apple TV series Ted lasso
who was visiting the White House to meet
with President Joe Biden about mental
health awareness soon after taking the
stage Gene Perry was pelted with
accusations of discrimination from today
news Africa correspondent Simon um
attiba
Jean pair uh Jean pair tried to hush the
reporter saying we're not doing this she
told him repeatedly but he kept pressing
I think we have that footage let's watch
that
yeah right you're right you're here for
me right for me no no no no no
weakness
you listen against me and discriminating
against some people in the Britain and
I'm saying that this is not China this
is not Russia is not Russia okay
foreign
[Music]
welcome welcome to the Press briefing
room okay
are you ready are we gonna behave
while many folks
all right so he's a parent I guess he's
upset that he hasn't been uh I don't
know all the
okay we could stop I don't know all the
details behind his particular gripe but
apparently from what I could tell he's
upset that he hasn't been called on in
seven months which seems fair to me I
mean you've been sitting there for seven
months and they won't ask you a question
uh
so I'm on his side
I'm well I'm automatically on his side
because he's uh because he's annoying
Karen Jean pair so automatically I
sympathize with him no matter what his
gripe is
um and I especially sympathize because
this uh White House is a total joke and
a farce and an embarrassment to us all
and which is evidenced by that image of
uh you know the White House Press
briefing and the cast of Ted lasso is
standing in the background
and a white with everything going on in
the world
that even this white house I mean they
tell us all the time it's we're facing
uh a crisis from all these different
directions the world's about to end
because of climate change Russia is on
the verge of taking over the world I
mean this is what they tell us
and you have time
to bring in the cast of Ted lasso at the
White House
and they're there to advocate for mental
health why would
why are they experts on mental what
because they make a TV show they make a
feel-good TV show
and so that makes them experts on Mental
Health
I mean these are the people they're all
about credentialism usually there it is
the the image
so usually it's all it's uh all we ever
hear is credentialism from the left or
from Democrats well what are your
credentials where did you go to school
to become an expert in this and then
they turned to the cast of Ted lasso
to be mental health experts at the White
House
I tell you something uh to these guys if
if you want
for one thing if you want to help
everyone's mental health then make a
better TV show how about that
okay your TV show is so that that hurts
my mental health I tried to watch Ted
lasso and it deeply damaged my mental
health because the show was terrible and
it was and it was made even worse
because it made me lose faith in
humanity just a little bit more
because all of these people were saying
you got to watch Ted lasso it's a great
it's amazing it's an incredible show it
wasn't just like oh it's mildly amusing
people said it was incredible it's a
great show and so I sat down with my
wife and I said let's it's everyone
saying it's a great show including
people that I used to trust and respect
we sat down to watch it and it was like
kind of charming for maybe
a total of about 47 minutes of run time
and then from then on out it was it was
terrible and I'm watching it and I
actually watched
um
I didn't watch every episode but I saw
enough because I I'm sitting there like
almost like
in slack jawed amazement
it's like this is Everyone likes this
show this is awful
it's just it's trite it's syrupy corny
like over the top and then and then and
then also you get into it's the the
character motivation still making it's
one of those shows where they here's
what happened with the show they have uh
they had an idea for a skit but it's
like like a kind of amusing skit
um which would have been it would have
been a good skit for four and a half
minutes but now they're trying to
stretch it into multiple seasons of a
series and they ran out of material very
quickly and uh that's how you end up
with one of these shows where the um
you know some of the characters they
their personalities change out of
nowhere it's not even character
development where there are gradual
changes but just like out of nowhere
they become the opposite of what they
were in the last episode because they
the writers just need the characters to
do whatever is needed in this particular
moment to get through the episode
um and they need the characters to
assume whatever motivation works for
this particular plot line there isn't
it's not necessarily cohesive with the
whole so it's one of those shows anyway
just a really a a bad show and uh it
hurt my own my mental health suffered
because of it
and so if I was in that White House
Press briefing room I would want to hold
them accountable for that
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
you know so many of us have lost faith
in the government in media in schools
while the good news is that there's
something you can do to help get the
country back on track prageru is an
educational non-profit that is fighting
with us to save the future of America
um
the five million times a day the videos
are watched Prager you video spread
messages of Liberty economic freedom and
judeo-christian values to the Next
Generation there truly is hope for
America but only if we reach more young
people and prageru is doing that every
day but they need your help to really
achieve their goals go to prageru.com
make a tax deductible donation whatever
you give right now will be matched and
have triple the impact so donate ten
dollars at triples to thirty dollars
give fifty dollars it becomes 150 this
is the kind of math I can do uh you get
the idea go to prageru.com make a tax
deductible donation whatever you give
will be tripled today
quick update for you in the never ending
battle with my wife over the giant
stuffed walrus we reached an impasse uh
yet again last night
um I'm afraid to say she threatened
physical violence against Johnny
uh threatening to cut it into pieces and
throw it in the garbage while I'm at
work and that's what you said and I
don't know what else to do I've already
compromised you know I
I brought the giant life-size walrus
home I thought it'd be a source of joy
for everybody we put it initially in the
living room as a conversation piece
um I think it makes for good
conversation anyway but for some reason
she didn't like it there and so I
actually
compromise you have to compromise in a
marriage and so I I compromised and I
moved it which by the way moving this
damn thing is not easy as a Herculean
feed all on its own I moved this thing
into the boy's bedroom uh the two older
boys and and uh and I I did this to keep
it safe
um because I frankly I don't trust my
stuff walrus around my wife and that is
a difficult thing for me to even say out
loud like what what do you do when you
get to a point in your marriage where
you don't trust your stuff walrus around
your spouse anymore
um and so I I said well I got to protect
Johnny
and uh and I thought this was also this
all this would also be a wake-up call
for my wife that she would realize that
um I felt so unsafe with this walrus
around her that you know I had to move
it into a different room
but instead it's not good enough because
now she says well it's taking up half of
the boys room and they don't even have
room for a dresser in their room because
of the walrus and so now their their
clothes are all over the floor because
there's no room for anything else they
can't even open the closet because the
walrus is there which is true
but my point is that even if they had a
dresser and they had access to their
closet they still wouldn't use it okay
these are young boys I I was one at one
time I just all the clothes are going
all over the floor anyway so just forget
about forget your dreams about well they
can't open their closet to hang their
clothes up you think a nine and
six-year-old boy are gonna hang their
clothes up
no it's going all over the floor anyway
so they might as well have the walrus in
there this is my point
and uh but then it just it came to an
impasse and she's she's like trying to
set
ultimatums for the walrus and I don't
know where to go from it I will say is
my one note on this is that I will admit
that she has offered a third solution
which is to bring the walrus all the way
down to my office uh that we just
finished Remodeling and building out
recently and there is room in my office
for the walrus but I have said no to
that because because there's a certain
aesthetic I'm going for in the office
and uh in my office and the walrus
doesn't work for that aesthetic
so it's got to be somewhere else in in
someone else's room or in the main
family room
and I'm realizing that I shouldn't have
admitted that out loud because I think
all the sympathy that I've built up is
probably now going to evaporate when you
realize that there is an area of the
house where she would want the walrus
but I'm saying no but you have done you
know
forget I said that the point is
I'm doing everything I can to protect
Johnny
all right um
let's see Kat says I hate the 50 50
split mentality if a wife is at home all
day and the man is away at work then why
shouldn't she take care of 80 to 90 of
the housework does her husband expect
her to take care of 50 of his job
well exactly exactly right and she
should also take care of 80 to 90
percent of the stuffed walrus
maintenance as well
another point that I've made
um
schizo says I think people wore the
masks out of fear of psychopaths
freaking out on them in public uh yeah I
think there's there's a lot of
motivations part of it was that the
social shame some of it was just pure
obedience to Authority some of it was
paranoia over the germs and all the rest
of it so there was a lot that went into
it but as I said yesterday you know I um
I almost would prefer to think that the
uh
the near 100 obedience that I observed
in many circumstances for masking was
driven by paranoia over germs
instead of just people sort of blindly
obeying Authority which I think is what
a lot of it was
um
Sean says never has the establishment
been terrified by someone more than
Donald Trump which is exactly why he
needs to win in 2024.
yeah I
I would love to hear you explain why you
think that I I'm not exactly sure that
that is the case that the establishment
is afraid of Donald Trump I it seems to
like all evidence seems to suggest that
uh they very much want Donald Trump to
be in the conversation they want him to
be the nominee because they think they
can beat him in the general election now
if you disagree that they could beat him
in general election that's one thing but
they obviously think they can beat him
um and this is not all speculation on my
on my end by the way you know this this
is is actually true that in the 22 uh
midterms
Democrats were funding and supporting uh
some of Trump's you know preferred
candidates
in the primaries because they wanted to
run against them in the general election
because they thought they could beat him
and in many of those cases they did beat
them
so
that is also something to take into
account here
Alex says Matt since it's the 20th
anniversary of the Iraq invasion I'm
curious where you stand on the war and
where you stood when it started where uh
well where I stand on it now is and it
was an unmitigated disaster which we
launched on false pretenses and which
did absolutely nothing to make us safer
and had the opposite effect
um so I stand where most people stand
now I mean you very rarely hear anyone
I'm not sure I've heard anyone period in
years defend the Iraq invasion uh where
did I stand on it at the time well I I
will admit I was in favor of it at the
time but I was also 16 years old like as
a junior or sophomore in in high school
when it happened and um so I can
remember I can remember being being
duped and fooled by the rhetoric and the
reasoning that was being given to us by
The Establishment for the Iraq War but
again
16 years old so I think that that uh
can perhaps be excused
and
finally
obn says wow actually not trolling here
good marriage advice 50 50 poisons
marriages exactly at the end of the day
it's that it works and you're both happy
not some I did this so you have to crap
it's both of your lives better each
other yeah the other problem with with a
50 50 um well not really the other
problem dude but just to flesh out this
idea
it's the same problem we've been talking
about when you have the 50 50 strategy
uh in order to make it exactly 50 50. it
requires score keeping you know it
requires this maybe not actual literal
score keeping on a on a scoreboard
somewhere in the house
you know most most marriages don't get
to that point maybe some do though but
it it becomes a mental score keeping
thing
um where both of you are scoring
yourselves because you have this image
of like I have to do half and she does
half and one of the problems there is
that is that you're going to score
yourself differently than your scout
spouse scores you
so you're going to give yourself a
certain number of points to get to that
um but it's almost guaranteed that your
spouse is not going to in assign you the
same number of points as you have
assigned yourself and so that becomes
the battle of
well I did 50 you did 50 you know but
each spouse is going to going to claim
well I well I actually have done 75
percent
you're struggling to do 25 percent
it's just constant score keeping it's
competition you know competitiveness has
no place in a marriage as I've said it's
it's if there's any place for it if you
need an outlet for competition in a
marriage that's what board games are for
and and board games can get very intense
and that's okay I know they do with my
wife but
um when it comes to day-to-day you know
living in your marriage there should be
no place for competition there
you know some recent and a very alarming
statistics show that more than a third
of Millennials approve of Communism it's
only because they don't know actual
history or they believe that it wasn't
communism because real communism hasn't
been tried as they say but it has been
tried and if you watch the first two
episodes of the new daily wire plus
series called what we saw Cold War
you'll see just how horrific it really
was when it was tried in fact
um here's a clip from Cold War check it
out
Russia was cluttered with dots marking
each of these places which looked like
ants scurrying across the map of the
world's largest country
423 of these dots would eventually be
built and here's what they would be
called in Wikipedia the Russian is Gulag
it means Maine Administration camps it's
an acronym
that acronym for the series of what were
called main Administration camps Gulag
was strung out like an island chain in
what one of their residents Alexander
solchenitson would refer to as the gulag
archipelago one of these dots just won
was located in Colima
nobody knows how many people actually
died in the gold mines of Colima all
agree that in winter time the
temperature in and around the camp was
the only place where by coincidence both
Fahrenheit and Celsius scales happen to
converge and that is at 40 degrees below
zero for each of them initial estimates
of 3 million people killed a Coloma
alone were no doubt too high the lowest
well-researched figure is about five
hundred thousand and the actual total
most likely was around 800
000 human Souls now that means that
Colima is almost certainly tied for
second place with Treblinka at eight
hundred thousand dead on the leaderboard
from hell it's unlikely but it's
entirely possible that the total death
in this worst single island of the 423
islands in the gulag archipelago
exceeded the 1.1 to 1.6 million people
killed at Auschwitz no one's ever heard
of kolama because unlike with Auschwitz
and Treblinka and belsek and sobabor
there are no pictures that survive from
these death camps in Cold War
Storyteller and writer Bill Whittle will
take you back to the beginning just
after World War II when the struggle
between communism and freedom began its
actual history were verifiable facts
come to life Cold War comes out today
and we're making the first episode
available for everyone to see so go to
dailywire.com cold warnow to watch it if
you want to keep watching got to become
a member so go to dailywire.com Cold War
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well the last time I brought up this
subject it resulted in a two-week news
cycle about translucent mermaids so
we'll try to beat that record this time
around Halle Bailey who I have to keep
being reminded is a person completely
distinct from Halle Berry has been doing
the media rounds in preparation for the
release of the live-action Little
Mermaid which I think comes out soon uh
in which bayley plays the race swapped
version of the titular character
other adjustments in edits made this
time around were being told as up rocks
reports quote Hallie Bailey has a
monster year in store her leading turn
as Ariel in Disney's Little Mermaid live
remake is out in May but her Ariel doll
is already in demand Bailey is also set
to Star as Nettie in The Color Purple in
December and she talked about the weight
of both roles as the cover star of
Edition modern luxuries addition Modern
Luxury is that that's the whole Magazine
anyway addition modern luxury's March
issue in the accompanying cover story
bayley explained how 2023 is a Little
Mermaid Left Behind the original
version's shades of sexism quote I'm
really excited for my version of the
film because we've definitely changed
that perspective of just her wanting to
leave the ocean for a boy it's way
bigger than that it's about herself her
purpose her Freedom her life and what
she wants she continued as women we are
amazing we are independent we are modern
we are everything and above and I'm glad
that Disney is updating some of these
themes
Bailey has transparently talked about
the horrifically racist backlash he's
been subjected to since her Casting in
2019. she did so again with addition
quote seeing the world's reaction to it
was definitely a shock but seeing all
the baby's reaction all the brown and
black young girls really tore me up
emotionally it's not only honestly been
such a crazy ride and I genuinely feel
shocked and honored and grateful to be
in this position a lot of times I have
to pinch myself and be like is this real
life
now
you should know that the um claim of
horrifically racist backlash is
supported with a link to an article from
the same website a few years ago also
claiming that there was racist backlash
but neither the original article nor
this new one ever specifically cite any
example of racist backlash this is a
trend that holds true for almost any
article or media report about racist
backlash against this film or racist
backlash against any other film
you'll you'll hear about the backlash
you can read stories about the backlash
the actors in the film will speak out
bravely against the backlash people will
denounce the backlash but nobody will
ever show you the backlash
you never actually see where this
backlash is happening
because it's mostly fictional the racist
backlash against The Black Mermaid is as
fictional as the mermaid herself in
truth very few people have actually
complained that the mermaid is black and
the few who have mentioned the race like
myself for example I've mentioned it
have made points that can't be
reasonably construed as racist by any
thinking person which is why they won't
provide any examples of what we're
actually saying so in my case just to
review
I am opposed in general to these Dei
race swaps of classic characters for two
reasons one
back to the theme of double standards if
it went the other way
every single one of these media Outlets
would be condemning it as racial
appropriation all of them and we all
know they would
okay I happen to believe in holding his
people to their own standard which means
that since they would complain about
black characters being made white we
should call them out for making white
characters black this is not our
standard but theirs if so-called
whitewashing is a problem then so is
black washing you don't get to make up
different rules or at least if you do
we're going to call you out on it that's
it
two there is an obvious Point behind the
race swaps it's not a matter of them
simply hiring the actor who happens to
have the best audition to return to an
example I've used before Morgan
Freeman's character in Shawshank
Redemption was written to be a white
Irish guy hence the name red
but nobody ever complained that they
made him black most don't even know that
the character was supposed to be white
because they didn't make him black for
the sake of him being black they made
him black because Morgan Freeman was
made for that role and it's impossible
to imagine anyone else playing it
that's the kind of race swapping that no
one has a problem with or should have a
problem with but it's different these
days because now they specifically look
for a non-white actor to take these
traditionally white roles this is an
actual targeted and intentional campaign
to minimize the number of White
characters on screen there's no question
that they're doing this they'll tell you
that they're doing it
and given those intentions I object
I think it's a bad thing to
intentionally erase white people you
know white people from films by erasing
White characters I don't think you
should do that and it gets worse the
more they do it the latest now is the
new Peter Pan film where both Peter Pan
and Tinkerbell have been made non-white
and then a few of the lost boys have
been made into girls as well again
none of this is happenstance as a result
of casting the best actors for the roles
if it was then who cares it was a
decision made ahead of time
to find someone who was not white to
portray these traditionally White
characters
now of course they celebrate the race
swabs they speak tearfully about what it
means for quote black and brown children
to be quote represented by yet another
white character turned black but if you
dare suggest
that white children will feel less
represented
you'll be mocked and screamed at and
accused of making a big deal out of the
thing that they themselves are insisting
is a big deal
I mean they're crying about how great it
is and then if you say you know I I'm
not sure that I really agree why are you
making such a big deal about this
that's the game here they erase the
White characters they applaud themselves
loudly for doing it but if you notice
what they're doing and you say even one
word about it
your petty and ridiculous and also of
course racist
you say
indeed this very segment is guaranteed
to end up reported by left me left-wing
media Outlets with a headline like Matt
Walsh goes on crazed racist rant about
Little Mermaid
there's no way of discussing the very
open very clear very intentional agenda
of minimizing white representation on
screen without automatically being
accused of petty bigotry This Is How
They rig things the ultimate crime
according to the left is the crime of
noticing they do things they do these
things loudly and proudly but you cannot
notice that they are doing the things
to Simply notice it is to commit a grave
sin of some kind
but of course with these woke remakes
it's not just about adjusting the racial
makeup of the characters it's also about
updating the themes as Bailey says in
this case they're going to correct some
of the sexism quote unquote of the
original by ensuring that the mermaid
leaves the ocean not to chase some dude
but to pursue her own personal
fulfillment after all Bailey clarifies
women are all amazing and they're
independent and they're modern
and she's right about that last point at
least I mean all women living today are
modern in the sense that they are living
today
not much of an achievement though I mean
being born at this point in the
chronology of human events is not in
itself a virtue nor does it
automatically make you you write or does
it vindicate your your value systems
just because it happens to be the thing
that's happening right now
this is a fact that comes as news to
progressives as chronological snobbery
is a characteristic inherent to
progressivism I mean it's right there in
the name of the ideology
recently we've discussed the growing
scourge
in the publishing world called
sensitivity readers and these are the
woe call monitors who are paid to read
old books sometimes new books do and
make updates to the author's language
and themes so that they reflect leftist
values and often these updates are made
without the author's consent because
often the author is dead it cannot
consent and this is essentially what
Disney is doing with its own catalog
right now
um I wouldn't be very surprised if they
actually hired sensitivity viewers to
watch the old cartoons and make
suggestions about how best to bring them
into Conformity with current left-wing
sensibilities
but whatever the process they follow
this is what they're doing and just as a
sensitivity readers are hamstrung by
their inability to understand the text
that they're butchering
the same goes for the woke updators at
Disney
I mean it's bad enough that they're
cannibalizing their own intellectual
property worse they don't even
understand their own intellectual
property
I mean I last watched The Little Mermaid
uh all the way through like 30 years ago
I guess
and even I remember that in the original
version uh the The Little Mermaid was
already motivated to leave the ocean
before she met the guy she sang a whole
song about it didn't she
so the the girl power I want to break
free from my patriarchal father
politically correct motif
was already firmly in place in the
original
their brilliant idea for modernizing the
story then is just to do more of that
at the expense of further minimizing the
classical romance elements
this is how they add Nuance you know
when you always hear them talk about
Nuance oh we're making it more nuanced
well they add Nuance by removing Nuance
so that the characters are motivated
entirely by Boring self-actualization
mumbo-jumbo mumbo jumbo rather than just
partially being motivated by boring
self-actualization mumbo-jumba
in fact this is how the left updates
everything from movies to books even
buildings
right for anything at all that they're
updating it means remove the Romantic
elements remove the the fanciful
elements remove anything that's like
beautiful creative unique like take all
that out
and replace it with a bland or more
banal
uglier version of what it already was
this is what they're doing with our
entire culture
which is why this Disney stuff is
important because it is just one
manifestation of this larger
far-reaching campaign and that is why
the whole campaign not just the new
Little Mermaid
is today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block hope
to see you there and uh if you want to
join us there you can become a member
and by using Code wall should check out
for two months free on all annual plans
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]